hey leute herzlich willkommen zum ersten
video aus dem urlaub die letzten videos
waren ja zwei mal minecraft maus die
hatte ich im voraus produziert und jetzt
nehme ich zum allerersten mal hier aus
den österreichischen bergen auf ich
hatte ja vor einigen tagen dieses
erkennst du diese youtuber an drei
merkmalen video aufgenommen und es kam
ziemlich gut bei euch an und tahir der
das video gemacht hat damals hat ein
neues video hochgeladen und das heißt
einfach nur ansage an kram crafter okay
also ich bin mal sehr gespannt was
hinter diesem video steckt wir gucken
uns das gleich mal zusammen an ich hab
schon so eine kleine vermutung aber
schauen wir zusammen einen puffer doch
mal sehr dass er mich in seinem video
fertig machen müssen
hey leute was los bisher fünf von fünf
erraten der minister vor der youtube wo
flügen suchen was auch immer und canon
de facto viel oder aber die fragen sind
relativ leicht kommen schon italien
eishockey wenn du das siehst hier mache
eine extrem version okay leute ich ahne
worum es geht ich hab's ja darüber mache
eine extrem version wahrscheinlich wird
es jetzt die mega version davon also gut
magst du so gerne eine extreme version
haben wolltest habe ich natürlich eine
völlig gemacht aber erstmal keine
zuschauer ich bin ja hier vorab falsche
die ersten teile von maxxim luca nicht
gesehen habt dann schaut euch die
unbedingt als erstes an weil die echt
cool geworden sind und ihr eventuell
auch mehr von dieser folge fest steht
klickt dazu einfach hier über deren
köpfe oder den ersten link in der
beschreibung an max und luca haben euch
da die links zu den jeweiligen folgen
hin gepackt hoffe ich zumindest auf
jeden fall habe ich mich für dieses mal
etwas neues und kulig überlegt und zwar
gibt es nur zehn personen die man
erraten muss aber dafür umso mehr zeit
weil das quiz extremist und jetzt passt
auf falls einer von den jungs nicht mehr
als 5 schaffen sollte muss eine
bestrafung macht und der andere darf
demjenigen dann eine bestrafung geben
und maxi ich will deine entscheidung
nicht beeinflussen oder so aber ehrlich
gesagt ich hab noch nie wirklich badawi
gegessen die roja bei auftritt ins video
gekommen ist weiß ich jetzt
ach so und es sind zwar immer noch drei
merkmale aber nur zwei richtige die euch
wirklich weiter helfen also das erste
merkmal sagt immer auf die person
männlich oder weiblich ist okay das war
alles was zu sagen wollte freitag das
gefällt mir mehr ballast gerne eine
bewertung darf und ja dir viel spaß und
erfolg maximo okay das wird richtig
richtig schwierig erst nochmal dickes
dankeschön alltag ich meine das ist ein
echt aufwendiges video schon wieder und
ich kann mich nur sehr bedanken weil ich
bin grad im urlaub und deshalb bin ich
super froh dass ich so ein für mich
einfach auf video aufnehmen kann er
fährt super viel arbeit reingesteckt
also unbedingt auf seinem kanal vorbei
schauen ist verlinkt er hat jetzt gerade
gesagt dass bei luca auch noch ein video
kommt das stimmt lukas kommt
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten paar
tagen irgendwann aber er macht für luca
auch noch mal so eine extreme challenge
okay los geht's nummer eins
sebastian wie sehen diese zeichen
männlich weiblich das habe ich raus
geschnitten
ok also männlich eine andere person mit
der youtube technisch inzwischen nicht
mehr zu tun hat hat ihn damals aus
seiner alten gaming kategorie rausgeholt
und ihn in eine neue gebracht und ihm
starthilfe gegeben hat ist unter anderem
2014 mit der person ein gemeinsames
projekt am laufen
oh gott ich glaube er weiß ich glaube es
geht um gott ich weiß es nicht nein es
ist doktor banks ja natürlich verdammt
de airways hat ja genau mit pixel wulff
minecraft gemacht da war ich auch dabei
hast du ich dachte wirklich es wäre weil
dort auch für black ops gemacht und
weiter männlich kommt nicht aus
deutschland dem nach klischee akzent aus
seinem land war in einem kurzen tv spot
von einem mobilfunkanbieter gott oh gott
in dem bruder von spot also ich denke es
geht und vodafone da war et crime auf
jeden fall drin bundes deutschland
demnach klischee akzent aus seinem land
sagt studium beim studium weil es ja
falsch 1
bei einem handy spot im t- mobile
spotlight worauf habe ich mich
eingelassen
hauptsache ich sagte tahir so machen
extrem version das ist viel so einfach
und jetzt habe ich einfach nichts gesagt
okay aber respekt es ist wirklich
schwierig ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
es so schwer ist gott ich muss fünf
schaffen und für eine bestrafung und hat
das nächste kam schon nochmal drei
männlich sein eigener bruder hat schon
mal mit ihm kooperiert ich nicht er
kommt aus der szene wo die videos am
meisten klicks geben aber auch seine
zeit brauchen
die meisten klicks
vielleicht ist das logo weil der
bearbeitet seine videos ziemlich klasse
und ich hab noch nie was mit ihm gemacht
auf youtube ich sag mal logo moritz card
online basketball change agent ihnen
gemacht vorläufe ich fange gesagt gar
nicht klar
es gibt nun auch sieben weitere sachen
aber drei stück falsch und ich muss fünf
richtig wundervoll krieg wieder
irgendwie vettel strafe als würdig bei
minecraft nicht genug abbekommen
ein gutschein normal weiter männlich ist
nimmt schon seit jahren mit einem der
größten display deutschlands auf ein
weltbekanntes spiel ist zwar hier
geboren hat aber einen leichten akzent
und ist wegen seiner eltern ursprünglich
halb pole europas der größten player
deutschlands dehner wahrscheinlich will
aber wer nimmt mit den oft auf easy
peasy ich sage ich aber der kann er
aktien easy cash
nein leute da erwarte ich gerade so
kaputt hier ich krieg gar nichts
gebacken
also jetzt bin ich richtig interessiert
hättet ihr das gewusst ist es so schwer
gta online mit dem natürlich wusste ich
ich dachte schon an den aber ich dachte
halte sie aber der wollte dass er halt
nicht naja er wieder männlich der
großteil will ihm sein wahres alter
nicht abkaufen stempelt ihn als viel
viel jünger ab besitzt einen
führerschein und viele touch cruise
ich weiß das ist jetzt glaube ich hier
rat scheint da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher weil der tattoos und wer sieht
auch ziemlich ziemlich jung auswahl der
glaube ich die krankheit hat oder so ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher über die
hintergründe
aber ich glaube diesmal weiß ich
wirklich und dann hätte ich auch mal die
nummer eins erraten
und es ist ja hier ab heute 21 jahre das
glaubt man echt nicht aber jetzt habe
ich einen erraten jetzt muss ich einen
einzigen fehler darf nur am quai
weiblich seit dem ersten teil eines
veranstaltungs projekt mitgemacht als
spieler wurde beim zweiten teil dabei
was sie aber nicht als spieler
falls ich verschicke dann schicke ich
dir den punkt ob ihre eltern kommen aus
tschechien
und sie hat mehr als das doppelte deine
abonnentenzahl ich denke mal an hannibal
aber wobei ich dann im zweiten teil
dabei bin ich bei baruth 2 erst dabei
gewesen oder schon beim ersten war ich
glaube ich war im ersten war dabei aber
es könnte hannibal sein
ich bin mir nicht sicher aber hannibal
und kelly let's play poker
ich glaube hannibal war nämlich nur
diskutiert dass sie da irgendwie mal
mitmacht wird im ersten teil des
veranstaltungsprogramms mitgemacht als
spieler beim zweiten teil dabei war
ich glaube ich war nicht nein ich war
geht erst mal let's play poker fünf
dabei oder so aber nicht beim zweiten da
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
und er schreibt falls ich falsch liege
dann schenke ich dir den punkt gehörte
ich habe es zwar falsch gesagt aber ich
war auch auf der falschen fährte aber er
sagt falls er falsch liegt schenken wir
den punkt ich sag mal ich habe mich
kriegt im punkt geschenkt oder tahir und
das kannst du hauptstadt einrichten
ok dann habe ich jetzt zwei richtig viel
falsch muss noch drei richtig machen
ansonsten habe ich verklagt das ist so
schwierig okay leute nummer 7
tut mir leid für den autolärm unten
weidlich du hast mit der person schon
für eventuelle mehr als drei kanäle
etwas gedreht oder content stimmt
überhaupt nicht miteinander überein
ich denke die rede ist von die fashion
also diana zur löwen mehr als drei
kanäle weil auf ihrem kanal etwas
gedreht dann auf auf dem kanal
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher ansonsten
habe ich glaube ich noch nicht so häufig
mit weiblichen youtuber inkorporiert ich
glaube es ist diana zu lösen
bitte bitte gut leute ich bin echt
erleichtert jetzt habe ich drei sachen
richtig viele sachen falsch weil die
aufholjagd hier 4,8 es macht mir spaß
junge hat schon mal etwas youtube
technisches mit einem mit jemandem
gestartet von dem wirklich keiner
gerechnet hat ein familienmitglied macht
auch seit jahren youtube auf gott
oh gott
ein familienmitglied
wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch die brüder
gibb display selbst david o aber ich
habe absolut keine ahnung von dem die
rede ist ach komm scheint hier ach komm
schon
daher hat damit ja natürlich
gottes war so fies aber es ist die
extrem version
davor hatte ja gesagt dass unsere
youtube inhalte grundverschieden sind
also der von die von diana und hier
natürlich das was damit gemeint schon
mal mit dem man etwas gemacht ein
geschwisterpaar hat auf youtube
sebastian das war richtig fies ist war
richtig fies käme nicht dass gesunde
letztendlich in der neusten staffel des
mir bekannten größten projekts
deutschland teilnehmen
macht nebelig neben ok neben da wette
ich drauf neben macht den kombi dass in
letzter zeit falls er wieder weg bringen
will die ganz sicher auf den trendline
wegen seiner lustigen unterhaltsame art
also ich kann nur zustimmen falls jetzt
von nebel nie die rede ist ich finde er
macht richtig gute videos und er hat
auch ein ziemlich heißen humor also auf
twitter guter mann aber schauen wir mal
ob ich recht habe
ja es ist neben robert leute ich habe
jetzt ich habe fünf falsch das ist die
alles entscheidende frage oh mein gott
diese stellen richtig schwer
wenn ich sein bester freund ins youtube
gebracht er wird demnächst seinen
derzeitigen mitbewohner mit dem er schon
locker ein jahr zusammen lebt verlassen
und in eine andere stadt ziehen weil es
ihm angenehm ist derzeit sehr oft dahin
muss wegen fußballtraining erst coach
peter lempp peter der sein bester freund
ron hat es youtube gebracht
fußball-coach leben viele bekannte und
freunde von ihm viele leute drückt mir
die daumen dass das thema ist dann hätte
es geschafft brauche es ist so schwierig
komm schon 321 jamann
okay ich hab echt geschafft leute wie
hat er das ist jetzt vorbei ist kanal
alles leute der hammer der hammer ich
konnte jetzt leider nicht so laut sein
wie ich gerne sein wollte bei mir ist
das irgendwie ein bisschen unangenehm in
dem hotel wo wir wohnen irgendwie rum zu
brüllen oder sonst was vor allem ist da
direkt unten die straße und die vorfahrt
vom hotel und sonst hat deshalb war ich
jetzt nicht so laut oder so aber ich
kann euch sagen es hat so viel spaß
gemacht ich möchte man großes dankeschön
aussprechen
ich hab's wirklich um ein haar nur
geschafft um ein haar weil er halt diese
let's play poker sache falsch ich muss
selbst schon mal nachgucken ob es
überhaupt stimmt weil vielleicht fahre
ich mich jetzt die ganze zeit und das ja
groß ist großes dankeschön an dich
thalia für dieses gute video dann würde
ich sagen schaut unbedingt bei luca
vorbei er macht ihr in den nächsten
tagen aus einem video und guckt auch
vorteile vorbei sobald lukas video
online ist stelle ich euch unten in die
beschreibung der link als gut und bis
zum nächsten mal